The question started right after Tobin and his husband moved to
这个问题出现在托宾和他丈夫搬到湾区并一起买了房子之后。
the Bay Area and got a house together.
湾区，然后一起买了房子。
Tobin's family was pretty excited about this. They all live within an hour. And they brought meals over for weeks. His mom bought them shades. But this question popped up.
托宾的家人对此感到非常兴奋。他们都住在离那不到一小时路程的地方。他们连续几周给他们送饭。他妈妈给他们买了窗帘。但这个问题突然冒了出来。
And the first time I noticed it happening, it was with my aunt. Kind of out of nowhere, she was like, oh, Which one of you is handy? Is one of you handy?
我第一次注意到这种情况是在我姑妈身上。她毫无预兆地问：“噢，你们俩谁比较擅长做家务？或者谁比较手巧？”
And I was just like, why does she want to know that? Why does she care?
我当时就在想，她为什么想知道这个？她为什么要在意这个？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
And I had, like, feelings about it, and I couldn't tell why. And then, it just kind of kept happening with other family members. Like, they would be talking about, oh, you guys moved in together into this house. Which one of you is handy?
我对这个问题有些想法，却说不出为什么。后来，这种情况在其他家庭成员身上也接连发生。比如，他们会聊到：“噢，你们一起搬进这所房子了。你们俩谁比较手巧？”
And on its face, it was kind of like, oh, we know when you're in a house, there's a lot of things to fix and a lot of things to do. But it felt like there was something else happening there, and it kind of bothered me.
表面上看，这好像是说：“噢，我们知道你们住进新房，有很多东西要修理，有很多事要做。”但总觉得背后还有别的意思，这让我有点困扰。
Something else there, like there was a question underneath the question that they were trying to get the answer to.
背后有别的意思，就好像他们问的问题下面还藏着另一个他们想得到答案的问题。
Yeah, like there was something else trying to be figured out. And I don't know. Like, the more I thought about it and why I was having feelings about it, it was kind of like this weird aha moment of, like, oh, I think you're asking who the man is in my relationship.
对，就好像还有别的事情想弄清楚。我不知道。我越是思考为什么我会对此有这种感觉，就越有一种奇怪的顿悟：“噢，我觉得你们是在问，在我们的关系里谁是‘男人’。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Right. You're both men.
没错。你们都是男人。
Yes.
是的。
But one of you is really the man.
但你们中有一个才是真正的“男人”。
Yes. Yeah.
是的，没错。
Then, when Tobin would tell them that it was his husband who was the handy one, he felt like he was just giving them ammunition to put a picture of their relationship that just bugged him, like they were being sized up into familiar categories. Which of you is the husband? Which of you is the wife?
后来，当托宾告诉他们是他丈夫比较手巧时，他觉得这反而给了他们借口，让他们能用一种令他反感的刻板印象来看待他们的关系，就好像他们被强行套进了熟悉的类别里：你们俩谁是丈夫？谁是妻子？
Like, it was weird, because whenever they would ask it, I could feel myself getting defensive. I didn't want to give them that picture. And I think part of my defensiveness came from, I think-- well, oh, man, not to take us in a whole other direction. But if you spend any amount of time in the closet--
这很奇怪，因为每当他们问起时，我就能感觉到自己变得很有防御心。我不想给他们那种印象。我觉得我的防御心部分源于……唉，不谈这个了，别把话题带向另一个方向。但如果你在衣柜里待过一段时间——
"In the closet." For Tobin, that means middle school and high school.
“在衣柜里。”对托宾来说，这意味着初中和高中的那段时光。
I think you're afraid of being found out at all as being effeminate in any way. Like, I know for me, I was very conscious of if anyone could detect, quote unquote, you know, "feminine" traits about me, and then figure out if I was gay or not. And so I do think that myself and a lot of gay men carry that around for kind of the rest of your life. And so I think that comes up in having to answer a question like this also.
我觉得你会害怕被发现有任何女性化的一面。我知道我自己当时非常在意是否有人能察觉到我身上所谓的“女性”特质，从而判断我是不是同性恋。所以我认为，我和许多男同性恋者在余生中都背负着这种心理阴影。因此，我觉得当被问到这种问题时，这种心态就会表现出来。
Yeah. Yeah, it's funny, because it's like this innocent question, and then really, underneath it, it's like there's a bomb waiting to go off, actually. Like, there's so many feelings.
是啊。有趣的是，这听起来像是个无心的问题，但实际上，问题下面埋着一颗随时会爆炸的炸弹。真的，里面包含了太多的情绪。
Yeah, it feels like it hits on a thing, at least for me, that I spent a lot of time as a kid running from, or spent a lot of time trying to not have to answer.
是的，至少对我来说，这触及了我在孩童时期花费大量时间逃避或努力避免回答的问题。
Yeah.
是啊。
Like, how masculine am I? And is somebody else more masculine than I am?
比如：我有多男性化？以及，是否有人比我更男性化？
And, like, I do want to make room for the idea that they could have meant none of this, like, absolutely none of this.
而且，我确实想给他们留有余地，也许他们本意并非如此，完全不是那个意思。
Did you address it directly with any of them?
你有没有直接和他们谈过这个问题？
No, because that would be bonkers. [LAUGHS] To just say--
没有，因为那太疯狂了。[笑声]直接说——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh, you asked me who's handy. You're trying to say I'm not a man. Like, that-- the leap in logic to say that outright is so huge.
“噢，你问我谁手巧，你是在试图说我不是个男人。”这种逻辑跳跃太大了，根本无法直说。
Well, today on our program, questions that contain other secret questions inside of them, questions that are wolves in sheep's clothing, and all kinds of situations that we've all been in-- in dating, in talking to strangers, in dealing with the saddest things that ever happened to us, and more. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天我们的节目要讨论那些包含着另一个秘密问题的问题，那些披着羊皮的狼式问题，以及我们都经历过的各种情况——在约会中、与陌生人交谈时、处理生命中最悲伤的事情时，等等。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
OK, so instead of four different acts today, what we're going to do is we're going to present the show as four questions. Here's the first one. Question, Tell Me How You Feel About This.
好了，今天我们不打算分四个部分，而是将节目呈现为四个问题。这是第一个问题：告诉我你对此的感受。
So Tobin, who you just heard, is one of the editors here at our show. And really, the idea for today's program came out of a conversation that happened at a staff meeting. And what happened was, we all got talking about these kind of question traps, where it seems like somebody is asking about one thing, but the question is a proxy for trying to figure out something else. Tobin will explain more.
刚才你们听到的托宾，是我们节目组的编辑之一。实际上，今天节目的创意来自一次员工会议上的谈话。当时我们都在聊那种“问题陷阱”，即表面上看起来是在问一件事，但这个问题实际上是一个代理，目的是为了搞清楚别的事情。托宾会详细解释。
The conversation was about the questions people ask on first dates, the kind that force who someone really is out into the open, maybe even without them realizing. One such question, I didn't even know was a thing. But a few of my co-workers said that for Black women of a certain age, it's having a kind of renaissance. Emanuele, our executive editor, asks it this way.
那场对话是关于人们在第一次约会时会问的问题，那些能强行让对方展现真面目的问题，甚至连他们自己都没意识到。其中有一个问题，我以前根本不知道还有这种操作。但我的几位同事说，对于某个年龄段的黑人女性来说，这个问题正在“复兴”。埃曼纽尔，我们的执行编辑，是这样问的：
"What do you think of Beyoncé?" It was a question that I found myself trying to ask, basically, a lot on first dates. Because it told me a lot about them. It's a question that tells you, one, in some ways, how they feel about a powerful Black woman.
“你觉得碧昂丝怎么样？”在第一次约会时，我发现自己总是不自觉地想问这个问题。因为它能告诉我的信息太多了。这是一个能反映出对方在某些方面如何看待一位强大的黑人女性的问题。
It's a question that tells you how they think about Black women in general, kind of, a little bit, to me. And that if you feel the need to put her down or say something negative about her, it's like a real turnoff. It's like a red flag, basically.
对我来说，这个问题在一定程度上也能反映出他们如何看待整体的黑人女性。如果你觉得有必要贬低她或者说她的坏话，那对我来说绝对是个“劝退点”。基本上就是一个红灯信号。
If they describe her singing style as kind of like caterwauling or like, ugh, she's just screeching--
如果他们把她的演唱风格描述为像是“嚎叫”或者“噢，她只是在尖叫”——
Bim, another producer, has also asked this question on many a date.
比姆，另一位制作人，也在很多次约会中问过这个问题。
All these words that have double meanings if you're a woman, and also if you're a Black woman-- I'm just like, all right, so you don't like loud people. OK. OK. That means you don't like me.
所有这些词汇，如果你是女性，特别是黑人女性，它们都有双重含义。我只会觉得：好吧，也就是说你不喜欢声音大的人。好的。OK，这意味着你也不喜欢我。
Could you tell me about some specific times that you've asked the Beyoncé question, and what the guy's response was and what it told you?
你能跟我讲讲你问过“碧昂丝问题”的具体几次经历吗？男方的反应是什么？这又向你传达了什么？
First date, bar date, pretty standard. Beyoncé actually came on in the bar in the background. I was like, oh, What do you think about Beyoncé?
第一次约会，在酒吧，很标准。背景音乐正好播到了碧昂丝的歌。我就问：“噢，你觉得碧昂丝怎么样？”
And he was like, I don't-- I don't understand what the big deal is about her. Like, you-- like, women act like they're in a cult or something. And it's like, they seem, like, crazy. I was like, oh, well, I really like her, and like, I don't really think I'm in a cult.
他说：“我不……我不明白她有什么大不了的。女性的表现就像她们在一个邪教里一样。看起来很疯狂。”我说：“噢，我真的很喜欢她，而且我不觉得我是在什么邪教里。”
Emanuele walks the guy through all the reasons Beyoncé is, in fact, pretty great. But the guy didn't budge.
埃曼纽尔给对方列举了碧昂丝确实非常出色的所有理由。但对方完全不为所动。
No, he did not-- didn't care to. And maybe he didn't care to hear me talk in general, is what it seemed like. (LAUGHING) So.
没有，他根本不关心。而且看起来他甚至不关心听我说话。（笑声）所以。
They did not go out again, because, well, you could say he was unapologetic when he fucked up the night. That's a play on a Beyoncé lyric, by the way. Sorry, couldn't help myself. Anyway, BA Parker, who's also been on the show-- she said, for her, it doesn't even have to be Beyoncé. Any well-known Black woman does the trick.
他们没有第二次约会，因为，嗯，你可以说他在搞砸那个夜晚时毫无愧疚。顺便说一句，这是对碧昂丝歌词的引用。抱歉，我忍不住。总之，也是本节目常客的BA·帕克说，对她而言，甚至不需要非得是碧昂丝，任何知名的黑人女性都可以达到目的。
If you say Serena Williams, and they say, oh, I think she's overrated, or if you say, Jada Pinkett, it's like, oh, she's too masculine, or she's ruining Will Smith's life, she's controlling him-- or How do you feel about Lizzo? Like, she needs to cover her ass. I bring up a Black female celebrity to get their opinion on them, and it usually becomes like the litmus test for how they would treat me as a partner, how they would view me as a person.
如果你提到塞雷娜·威廉姆斯，他们说“噢，我觉得她被高估了”；或者提到贾达·平克特，他们说“噢，她太男性化了”或者“她毁了威尔·史密斯的生活，她在控制他”；或者“你觉得利佐怎么样？”比如“她需要遮住屁股”。我会提起一位黑人女名流来获取他们的看法，这通常成了他们会如何对待我作为伴侣、如何看待我作为一个人的试金石。
But the Beyoncé question, she agrees, is the most potent. Because the answer can really tell you if you should be crazy in love or putting everything he owns in a box to the left. Again, I am so sorry. The thing about a bunch of people using the same trick, though, is that eventually, people-- in this case, men-- might catch on.
但她也同意，“碧昂丝问题”是最有效的。因为答案真的能告诉你，你是该坠入爱河，还是该把他所有家当装进箱子里扔出去。再次重申，我非常抱歉。不过，很多人使用同样的套路，久而久之，人们——在这种情况下，是男人们——可能会察觉到。
Are you aware of the Beyoncé question?
你知道“碧昂丝问题”吗？
Yes, I am aware of the Beyoncé question.
是的，我知道。
Emmanuel Dzotsi, producer and man at the show--
埃曼纽尔·佐齐，制作人，本节目的男性成员——
Have you experienced this?
你经历过吗？
Yes, I've experienced it many times.
是的，我经历过很多次。
He told me about a date he was on where they started talking about musicals, and the movie version of Dreamgirls came up. And thinking he was just answering a question about the movie, Emmanuel was honest. He said, Beyoncé was just OK in that. He didn't realize he was answering the wrong question.
他告诉我一次约会经历，他们开始聊音乐剧，谈到了电影版《追梦女郎》。埃曼纽尔以为自己只是在回答关于电影的问题，就老实回答了。他说：“碧昂丝在里面演得一般。”他当时根本没意识到自己是在回答一个错误的问题。
Um, and I was just digging a hole. [LAUGHS]
嗯，我当时简直是在自掘坟墓。[笑声]
She was just like, the only answer to being asked about Beyoncé is that, yes, she's fantastic. She's amazing. Nobody can do what she does.
她的意思是，当被问到碧昂丝时，唯一的答案就是：是的，她太棒了。她很惊艳。没有人能像她那样。
It was only later that he learned from another guy friend why he, as a Black man, should really only answer one way.
直到后来，他从另一位男性朋友那里才明白，作为黑人男性，为什么他其实只能有一种回答。
I remember my friend saying, basically, that is the question Black women will ask you to determine if you really like Black women. Once it was explained to me, like, I totally understood where people were coming from. And I understood what the purpose of that question was.
我记得我朋友告诉我，基本上，这就是黑人女性会问你的问题，用来判断你是否真心喜欢黑人女性。一旦解释清楚，我完全理解了她们的出发点。我也明白了那个问题的目的。
In some cases, the Beyoncé question is like an agreed-upon farce, where both parties know they're talking in code. Parker was recently on a date. She mentioned Beyoncé's Black is King film.
在某些情况下，“碧昂丝问题”就像是一场心照不宣的闹剧，双方都知道他们是在用暗语交谈。帕克最近去约会，她提到了碧昂丝的电影《黑人是国王》。
And he was like-- uh, (LAUGHING) He was like, I don't know what to say here. 'Cause I-- I-- I like this. I like talking to you, but I don't love Beyoncé. (LAUGHING) And I don't want you to be mad at me.
他说——呃，（笑声）他说：“我不知道该说什么。因为我……我喜欢这个。我喜欢和你聊天，但我并不爱碧昂丝。（笑声）我不希望你生我的气。”
He knew it was a trap.
他知道这是一个陷阱。
(LAUGHING) He did know it was a trap.
（笑声）他确实知道是陷阱。
And how did you respond?
那你怎么回应的？
I was like, What are you talking about? What are you-- And he was like, I know girls do this. And I was like, you're-- you're right. And I'm sorry.
我说：“你在说什么啊？你……”他说：“我知道女生会这样。”我说：“你是……你是对的。我道歉。”
(LAUGHING) I apologized. And I was like, well, I guess that's kind of the right answer. So we had a couple more dates.
（笑声）我道歉了。我说：“好吧，我想这确实是正确的答案。”所以我们又约会了几次。
Of course, there are other questions like the Beyoncé one-- little traps we set on dates, hoping the other person doesn't fall in, or hoping they do. One that made the news recently, which may or may not be true-- according to an old classmate, Governor Ron DeSantis would ask dates if they liked Thai food. But-- and this is key-- he'd pronounce it "Thigh" food.
当然，还有其他像“碧昂丝问题”一样的陷阱——我们在约会时设下的小陷阱，希望对方不要掉进去，或者希望他们掉进去。最近上新闻的一个例子——是真是假不确定——据一位老同学说，罗恩·德桑蒂斯州长会问约会对象是否喜欢泰国菜（Thai food）。但是——关键点在于——他会把它读成“大腿菜”（Thigh food）。
And if they said, no, it's Thai food, not "thigh," he'd ditch the date. It was his way of testing if they'd correct him, which he did not want. I don't know. It sounds like a test I'd be grateful to fail, but that's just me.
如果她们说：“不对，是Thai（泰国），不是Thigh（大腿）”，他就会中止约会。这是他测试对方是否会纠正他的方式，而他并不想被纠正。我不知道。这听起来像是一个我很高兴能挂科的测试，但这只是我的看法。
Anyway, I talked to a bunch of other people about their question traps. Kelsey in Minnesota asked her dates about their favorite Tom Hanks movies. She said he's been in so many movies across multiple genres, the answer is kind of like a personality test. Toy Story, for example, tells her there is a stunted-adolescence thing going on.
总之，我跟其他人聊了聊他们的“陷阱问题”。明尼苏达州的凯尔西会问约会对象他们最喜欢的汤姆·汉克斯电影。她说他演过那么多不同类型的电影，这个答案简直就像是一场人格测试。比如《玩具总动员》，就会告诉她对方有一种停滞不前的青少年心理。
Sarah in Tampa said when she started to get a weird vibe, she'd ask, What's your favorite conspiracy theory? Most people would keep their answers lighthearted, but occasionally, someone would go all in. One guy started talking all about Nazi separatists. She's Jewish, so you know, kind of a deal breaker.
坦帕市的萨拉说，当她开始感到不对劲时，她会问：“你最喜欢的阴谋论是什么？”大多数人会轻松作答，但偶尔有人会全盘托出。有个人开始谈论纳粹分裂主义。她是犹太人，所以你们懂的，这直接谈崩了。
But not all question traps are subtle. There's another genre that I was surprised anyone fell for-- the kind of question that seemed covered in yellow caution tape and a sign that said, this is a trap. This one comes from Vivian in Iowa.
但并非所有的陷阱问题都很微妙。还有另一种类型，我惊讶居然有人会上钩——那种看起来贴满了黄色警戒线、写着“这是陷阱”标志的问题。这个问题来自爱荷华州的维维安。
After her husband died in 2016, she found herself back out on the dating scene. Her question on a date was, If your ex walked by right now with their new partner, what would you do? Which was her way of asking a much more interesting question-- How fucked up was your last relationship?
她丈夫在2016年去世后，她重返约会市场。她在约会时的问题是：“如果你的前任现在带着新伴侣路过，你会怎么做？”这是她用来询问一个更有意思的问题的方法——“你的上一段感情有多烂？”
First time I did it, the guy said, I would punch him and give her a piece of my mind.
第一次问的时候，对方说：“我会打他一拳，然后让她听听我的意见。”
Oh, my god.
我的天。
(LAUGHING) Exactly. We had just sat down to have a nice lunch on a Sunday afternoon. So I'm like, do I get up and go, or-- [LAUGHS] And that's when the story came out of how he was still about a couple of weeks away from going to court for finalizing his divorce.
（笑声）没错。我们当时才刚坐下来，想在一个周日下午享受一顿午餐。所以我当时想，我是该起身走人，还是……[笑声]就在那时，他讲出了他当时离法院正式判决离婚只差几周的事。
And it had been a 38-year relationship, and he found out she had been cheating for most of the time, in a completely serendipitous way. She gave him an old phone that she had wiped, and when she downloaded the cloud, it downloaded into his phone, too. And that's how he found out.
那是一段38年的关系，他发现她大部分时间都在出轨，而且发现的方式非常偶然。她给了他一部她清空过的旧手机，结果当她同步云端时，信息也同步到了他的手机上。就是这样发现的。
Wow, you got so much information from that one question.
哇，你通过这一个问题得到了这么多信息。
You got to make it efficient. Why draw it out?
必须得高效。为什么要拖泥带水？
I was shocked. This question is so clearly, How bad was your last breakup? Do I have anything to worry about? But something about turning it into a fun little icebreaker made these guys open up.
我当时惊呆了。这个问题显然就是在问：“你的上一段感情有多糟糕？我有什么好担心的吗？”但不知为何，把它变成一个有趣的破冰话题，让这些男人们敞开了心扉。
There was another guy that said, well, we would have to leave immediately, because I don't want to see them. And my reply was, You don't want to see them, or you don't want them to see us?
还有另一个人说：“嗯，我们必须立刻离开，因为我不想见到他们。”我的回答是：“你是不想见到他们，还是不想让他们见到我们？”
And what was his response?
他怎么回应的？
Oh, he-- never answered directly. But I knew then that he was still in a relationship.
噢，他……从未直接回答。但我那时就知道他还在纠缠不清。
With her now-husband, they met at a widows' support group. He talked about his loneliness and being a single parent. They kind of just got each other.
至于她现在的丈夫，他们是在丧偶互助会上认识的。他谈到了自己的孤独和单身父亲的生活。他们就是那种心有灵犀的感觉。
And she knew the question, What would you do if your ex showed up? would not be right for this nice guy who had just lost his wife. She wasn't going to ask that.
她知道“如果前任出现你会怎么做？”这个问题，对于这个刚刚失去了妻子的好男人来说是不合适的。她不会问那个问题。
The last person I talked to was Jessica. She teaches ESL classes in Atlanta.
我聊的最后一个人是杰西卡。她在亚特兰大教英语。
What's your go-to question?
你的必杀技问题是什么？
Uh, "Do you believe in ghosts?"
呃，“你相信有鬼吗？”
Ghosts. I bet you didn't see that one coming, did you-- "Do you believe in ghosts?" Here's how Jessica says it works.
有鬼。我敢打赌你没料到这个，对吧——“你相信有鬼吗？”杰西卡是这样解释的。
There is no one right answer. It just matters that you and your partner have the same answer, essentially, at its core. Your minds kind of work in a similar way.
没有唯一正确的答案。重要的是你和伴侣从根本上拥有相同的答案。你们的思想以相似的方式运作。
Was there ever a time that you asked the ghost question, the person answered differently than you, and you went ahead and dated that person anyway? And how did that go?
有没有过你问了“鬼魂问题”，对方的回答和你不同，但你还是继续跟他约会了？结果怎么样？
[CHUCKLES] Yes. Yeah. I was engaged before I married my husband now. And the ghost question really should have been my get-the-fuck-out moment. [LAUGHS]
[笑声]有。是的。我和现在丈夫结婚前订过婚。那个“鬼魂问题”真的应该成为我赶紧分手的信号。[笑声]
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Her answer to the question is, I don't really believe in ghosts, but if there was evidence to the contrary, I could be convinced. I'm open to changing my mind.
她对那个问题的回答是：“我不怎么相信有鬼，但如果有相反的证据，我可以被说服。我乐于改变自己的看法。”
And his response was, no, and there is no information that you could give me to change my mind. And I just-- I don't see why anyone would really think that.
而他的回应是：“不，没有任何信息能让我改变看法。我实在不明白为什么有人会那么想。”
At the time, she didn't think much about the difference in their answers. But then, as she got to know him better, other things would come up.
当时，她没怎么在意他们答案的差异。但后来，当她更了解他时，其他问题也出现了。
And I was frustrated about the fact that, like, everything with you is so black-and-white. Like, not everything is black-and-white. Sometimes they're gray. And then I thought back to his answer to this question.
我对他那种凡事非黑即白的态度感到沮丧。并不是所有事情都是黑白分明的。有时是灰色的。然后我想起了他对这个问题的回答。
His rigidity was one of the big things that broke them up. Now, she tells everyone she knows, if you're seeing someone new, ask them the ghost question. It could save you a lot of time.
他的僵化是导致他们分手的主要原因之一。现在，她告诉每个认识的人：如果你在和新人约会，就问他们“鬼魂问题”。这能为你节省很多时间。
The thing about any trap, of course, is there are ways to sidestep it, disarm it. And then, the person who laid the trap has to decide what to do. Emanuele had to make such a decision.
关于任何陷阱，当然，都有规避或化解的方法。然后，设下陷阱的人就得决定该怎么做。埃曼纽尔就必须做出这样的决定。
Ironically enough, my current boyfriend had no idea who Beyoncé was-- who's the only person who had that response.
讽刺的是，我现在的男朋友根本不知道碧昂丝是谁——他是唯一给出这种反应的人。
What did that tell you?
这告诉了你什么？
That he just needed, like, some education?
他只是需要一点点“教育”？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He's older, and he's not from this country, and doesn't listen to music, really, and like, by the second date, he had read the entire Wikipedia page for me, and he knew Beyoncé's birthday, and that she was married to Jay-Z, and he knew about the elevator fight.
他年纪大一点，不是这个国家的人，也不怎么听音乐。到第二次约会时，他已经帮我读完了整页维基百科，他知道碧昂丝的生日，知道她和Jay-Z结婚了，还知道电梯斗殴事件。
So he listened to your opinion.
所以他听进了你的看法。
Yeah. It ended up being a green flag. Now, I talk to him about Beyoncé all the time, and I don't necessarily think he's, like-- he's not going out to Beyoncé concerts or anything, but he understands how important she is and how important she is to me, and lets me rant about her, so, that's all you ever really want, right?
是啊。这最后成了一个“绿灯”信号。现在，我总是跟他聊碧昂丝，我不一定认为他会……他不会去碧昂丝的演唱会什么的，但他理解碧昂丝对我的重要性，也允许我发牢骚，所以，这不就是你真正想要的吗？
It is. All I think anyone wants is someone you don't feel like you have to set a trap for, someone who you can look at them and say, you're everything I need and more. It's written all over your face. Baby, I can feel your halo. Pray it won't fade away. Sorry, I'm going to stop now.
确实。我想每个人想要的只是一个不需要你费心设下陷阱的人，一个看着他就能说：“你就是我需要的一切，甚至更多。”这都写在你的脸上了。宝贝，我能感受到你的光环。祈祷它永远不会褪色。抱歉，我要停下了。
Tobin Low is an editor on our program.
托宾·洛是我们节目的编辑。
Question Two, How Old Are Your Kids? So there's a particular piece of small talk that happens all the time that, for some people, is the most normal thing in the world, and for others, is a super delicate minefield.
第二个问题：你的孩子多大了？有些闲聊的话题对某些人来说是最自然不过的事，但对另一些人来说，却是极其微妙的雷区。
This story that you're about to hear is about a couple for whom it is a minefield. And how, one day, a question like this comes up, and it goes completely differently from how it's ever gone before for them, in a spectacularly wild way. You'll hear what I'm talking about. Chris Benderev tells the story.
你即将听到的故事，是关于一对将此视为雷区的夫妻。以及有一天，当这样一个问题出现时，它与他们过去经历的任何情况完全不同，且以一种极其疯狂的方式发生了。你会明白我在说什么。克里斯·本德雷夫讲述了这个故事。
Stacey Silberman is a real estate agent in Southern California, and she's well suited to the job because she's excellent at making conversation with strangers about anything. But for the past six and a half years, there's been this classic genre of get-to-know-you banter that's become a lot more complicated for her and her husband, Michael. And that's questions about their children.
斯泰西·希尔伯曼是南加州的一名房地产经纪人，她很适合这份工作，因为她非常擅长与陌生人谈论任何话题。但在过去的六年半里，有一种经典的交友闲聊对她和丈夫迈克尔来说变得复杂多了。那就是关于他们孩子的问题。
Um, yes, all the time. Talking to people, getting introductions-- it's always asking about our kids. How many kids do you have? Blah, blah, blah, blah. How old are they?
嗯，是的，总是这样。和人聊天、被介绍认识——总是会问到我们的孩子。“你有几个孩子？等等等等。他们多大了？”
The answers to these questions are complicated for Stacey, because her older child, Max, died in 2017.
回答这些问题对斯泰西来说很复杂，因为她的大孩子，马克斯，在2017年去世了。
So it has been six and a half years, because I have a dot tattoo for every six months.
所以已经六年半了，因为我每六个月就会纹一个小点点。
This is Stacey's husband, Michael, Max's dad. He's a CPA, straight-laced kind of guy, for the most part.
这是斯泰西的丈夫迈克尔，马克斯的爸爸。他是个注册会计师，大部分时候是个循规蹈矩的人。
Max always wanted us to get tattoos, and we never did. And I feel like--
马克斯一直想让我们纹身，但我们从未尝试过。我觉得——
I heard he had some. He had some.
我听说他有一些。他有一些。
He had a wonderful sleeve and lots of tattoos. But-- so I'm covered in tattoos, and my right arm is an entire memorial for Maxie. I've got the kids tattooed up here on my right shoulder, so.
他有一个很棒的袖套纹身，身上还有很多纹身。但……所以我全身都是纹身，我的右手臂是为了纪念马克斯的。我的右肩上纹着孩子们，所以。
Did you have tattoos before he died?
你在他去世前有纹身吗？
Never. But you know, it's-- tattoos are a very interesting thing. It's less than the least I can do, but it does help me through the pain, and tattooing really, how I see it from my perspective, is just socially acceptable cutting.
从来没有。但你知道，纹身是件很有意思的事。这微不足道，但确实能帮我熬过痛苦，而纹身，在我看来，只是社会可接受的自残方式。
Max was a funny kid, always loved playing pranks, who, by 15, was struggling with drug addiction, going in and out of treatment. He overdosed when he was 25 in his parents' house.
马克斯是个有趣的孩子，总是喜欢恶作剧。15岁时，他陷入了毒瘾，反复接受治疗。他在25岁时在父母家中服药过量去世。
And after he died, for a while, Michael and Stacey were around friends and family who knew what had happened. So nobody asked those "Do you have kids" sort of questions. But then Stacey traveled to a conference in Albuquerque.
他去世后，有一段时间，迈克尔和斯泰西身边都是知道真相的朋友和家人。所以没人问那些“你有孩子吗”之类的问题。但后来斯泰西去阿尔伯克基参加了一个会议。
She was sitting down for lunch next to a couple-- friendly, blonde woman and her husband. And they began asking Stacey where she was from and what she did-- and then, finally, those questions.
她午餐时坐在了一对夫妻旁边——友好的金发女郎和她的丈夫。他们开始问斯泰西来自哪里，从事什么工作——最后，问到了那些问题。
"Do you have kids?" "How old are they?" And the woman was, you know, kind of Southern, very sweet, very bubbly. And when people are like that with me, you know, I'm pretty open.
“你有孩子吗？”“他们多大了？”那个女人很随和，很甜美，很有活力。当人们那样对我时，你知道，我通常很坦诚。
And so I felt like being authentic. And I told her, you know, one of my children died of an overdose two years ago. And now, I have one.
所以我当时想表现得真实一点。我告诉她：“你知道，我的一个孩子两年前因吸毒过量去世了。现在，我还有一个孩子。”
This did not go over well.
这下弄得局面很尴尬。
This woman and her husband-- it really upset them. They couldn't-- they just couldn't handle the conversation. I just saw this major pity face, with the open mouth and the, oh, OK.
那个女人和她丈夫——他们真的很难过。他们处理不了这段对话。我看到她那种典型的怜悯表情，张着嘴，说着“噢，好的”。
And does the conversation with them kind of stall out at that point, and then they kind of go?
那场对话是不是就在那一刻陷入了僵局，然后他们就离开了？
Totally stalled. They never talked to me again.
完全卡住了。他们再也没有跟我说话。
Of course, over time, this happened again and again. Strangers would ask them these sorts of questions. And when they'd answer, it'd suck all the air out of the room, which made Michael especially uncomfortable.
当然，随着时间的推移，这种情况发生了一次又一次。陌生人会问他们这类问题。而当他们回答时，会瞬间抽干房间里的空气，这让迈克尔特别不舒服。
He never liked sharing this stuff with strangers. He's more of a private person. But together, he and Stacey came up with a strategy for how to handle things.
他从不喜欢跟陌生人分享这些。他是个更内向的人。但迈克尔和斯泰西一起商量出了一个应对策略。
When we're out and about and the question comes up, we look at each other just a little, imperceptibly so, so nobody could really pick up what's going on. And then usually, Stacey will answer however she answers, and I support her unreservedly.
当我们外出时遇到这个问题，我们会微微对视一下，动作很小，没人能察觉发生了什么。通常斯泰西会随口回答，而我无条件支持她。
A lot of the times, I actually lie. We have two kids. This is their ages. Talk to you later. [CHUCKLES] And keep it short and sweet.
很多时候，我其实是在撒谎。“我们有两个孩子。他们是这些年龄。回见。”[笑声]保持简短。
Because sometimes the white lie is better for that person. Because they're at a party, they're out having fun, and they definitely don't want to hear about your dead child.
因为有时小谎言对那个人更好。因为他们是在派对上，正在玩得开心，他们绝对不想听到关于你去世孩子的消息。
And so on they went, answering some questions about their kids and bobbing and weaving around others for six and a half years-- until this one day last November, when they got themselves into a situation that was very different from any that they'd been in before-- and very public.
于是他们就这样继续生活着，回答一些关于孩子的问题，同时巧妙地回避其他问题——直到去年十一月的那一天，他们陷入了一个与以往任何时候都不同的境地——而且是在极其公开的情况下。
One thing to know about Stacey and Michael is they both spend a lot of their time working at a recovery center for people struggling with addiction. And sometimes they hang out with the other staff and clients there.
关于斯泰西和迈克尔，有一点需要知道，他们两人大部分时间都在一家针对成瘾者的戒毒中心工作。有时他们会和那里的其他员工和客户一起聚会。
And so I saw that they were going to a show at the Hollywood Improv where Sarah Silverman was performing, and I'm like, oh, my god, I love Sarah Silverman. I want to go. I want to go.
我看到他们要去好莱坞即兴表演剧场看萨拉·西尔弗曼的表演，我就想：“天哪，我太爱萨拉·西尔弗曼了。我想去。我想去。”
And I said when we got there, I go, I want to sit front row, center. I want to get heckled. [CHUCKLES] I want to be right under Sarah Silverman. I want her to heckle me if possible. Or me-- I guess we heckle them. I don't know. I just wanted to be a part of it.
到那儿时我说，我想坐在前排中间。我想被嘲讽。[笑声]我想坐在萨拉·西尔弗曼正下方。如果可能的话，我想让她嘲讽我。或者我们嘲讽他们。我不知道。我只是想成为其中的一部分。
They get seats, front row center. But before Sarah Silverman came on stage that night at the Hollywood Improv, there was this opener-- guy named Adam Ray, early 40s, wearing a Mariners cap. And he's got this backing band-- drums, keyboard, backup singers.
他们坐在前排正中间。但在萨拉·西尔弗曼登台前，有个暖场表演者——一个名叫亚当·雷的家伙，40出头，戴着水手队的帽子。他有个伴奏乐队——鼓、键盘、伴唱。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
And he ends his set with a song about how all his friends with kids are miserable and boring now.
他以一首关于他那些有孩子的朋友如今变得多么悲惨、多么无聊的歌结束了他的表演。
(SINGING) A lot of my friends-- they have kids. Ooh, good for you. Ohhh, good for you. Who cares? Who cares? Who cares? Who cares?
（歌唱）我很多朋友……他们有孩子了。噢，那真是太好了。噢，那真是太好了。谁在乎呢？谁在乎呢？
But then the song shifts. Adam Ray says-- or sings-- that he and his wife are still deciding about having kids. And suddenly, he turns to the crowd, wants to find someone with kids who can make an argument for having them. Adam starts in the front row, with the guy a few seats away from Stacey and Michael.
但随后歌曲变调了。亚当·雷说——或者唱着——他和妻子还在考虑要不要孩子。突然，他转向人群，想找一个有孩子的人来为生孩子辩护。亚当从前排开始，找到了坐在离斯泰西和迈克尔几个座位远的一个男人。
(SINGING) Do you have kids?
（歌唱）你有孩子吗？
No!
不！
(SINGING) Hell, yeah.
（歌唱）见鬼，是的。
So the minute the word "kids" came up, I went on high alert. And I just had a feeling, oh, my god, we're sitting in the front row. Is he going to come to us?
听到“孩子”这个词的瞬间，我就进入了戒备状态。我心里有种预感：“天哪，我们就坐在前排。他会走过来吗？”
(SINGING) Do you have kids?
（歌唱）你有孩子吗？
Fuck no.
见鬼，不。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
(SINGING) Can somebody stick to the script.
（歌唱）能不能有人按剧本来。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I'm nervous, because I don't know what I'm going to say. I don't know how I'm going to deal with it. And remember, we're in a comedy club, and even though Stacey and I subconsciously communicate with one another, we can't do that here in this venue and look at each other and get an idea of, what are you thinking, what are you thinking, without talking.
我很紧张，因为不知道该说什么。不知道该怎么应付。记住，我们在喜剧俱乐部，即使斯泰西和我在潜意识里互通有无，在这种场合我们也无法看着对方交流想法而不用说话。
So I'm there, sort of, in a desert, waiting. And then, I saw him coming to me. Of course. So he comes to me, do you have any kids?
所以我当时像是在沙漠里等待着。然后，我看到他朝我走过来了。当然。他走到我面前：“你有孩子吗？”
(SINGING) Do you have kids?
（歌唱）你有孩子吗？
Damn right, I do.
该死，我当然有。
(SINGING) That's what I'm talking about!
（歌唱）这才是我想听到的！
Pretty assertive, for the guy who doesn't like talking about this.
对于那个不喜欢谈论这个的人来说，语气相当坚定。
I was thinking about, what are you-- fucking-- you don't have kids and you're proud? Like, shut the fuck up and get out. Right? You know? So there probably was a little attitude, perhaps. You think?
我当时在想，你这……该死的……你没孩子还那么自豪？闭上你的臭嘴滚吧。对吧？你知道的？所以大概有一点小情绪，你觉得呢？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And, uh, I figured that would be it.
而且，我以为到这儿就结束了。
But the comedian's not done with him.
但喜剧演员还没打算放过他。
(SINGING) How many kids do you have? Can you help change our minds today with whatever you say about the blessings kids come to be? How many kids do you have? Is it one? How many kids do you have? How many kids do you have? You have--
（歌唱）你有几个孩子？你能通过你说的话来改变我们今天关于孩子是福气的看法吗？你有几个孩子？是一个吗？你有几个孩子？
Two.
两个。
And he's still not done.
而他还没完。
(SINGING) Two, two kids. Which one is your favorite? There's always-- 'cause there's always one that you're like, you can go back inside your mom. The tall one or the short one? Which one is your favorite?
（歌唱）两个，两个孩子。哪个是你的最爱？总有一个让你想说“你还是回到你妈肚子里去吧”。高的那个还是矮的那个？哪个是你的最爱？
Which one do you want more than the other? They're definitely probably not here, so you can say, so you can say, which one you forgot the birthday of. You wouldn't mind if they took the bus to Irvine tonight. First of all, how old are your kids?
你更想要哪一个？他们肯定不在这儿，所以你可以说，你可以说，你忘了哪个的生日。你不介意他们今晚坐公交去尔湾。首先，你的孩子多大了？
So he finally comes down to me with a microphone-- How old are your kids? And that's where I was having difficulty calculating. Because nobody asks me how old they are, typically.
他终于拿着麦克风走到我面前了——“你的孩子多大了？”这就是我难以计算的地方。因为通常没人会问我他们多大。
So the first thing that went through my mind was-- well, Sabrina's 26, and by that time, I was fucked. Because there was no time to figure out, OK, so Max is 31. That didn't happen.
所以我脑子里闪过的第一个念头是——好吧，塞布丽娜26岁，在那一刻，我就完了。因为根本没时间去理清：“好的，那马克斯是31岁。”这根本没发生。
While Michael's thinking, Adam the comedian keeps holding the microphone, waiting. This dad is taking too long to answer. And then, finally--
在迈克尔思考时，喜剧演员亚当一直拿着麦克风等待着。这位父亲回答得太慢了。最后——
(SINGING) Oh, my god, you don't know. Wait a second. You're bringing down the energy of the show with your lack of knowledge of your kids.
（歌唱）噢，天哪，你不知道。等一下。你对孩子缺乏了解，这让演出的氛围变差了。
I felt protective over him in that moment. Like, that's a loaded question, and that's why he can't answer you.
那一刻我对他产生了一种保护欲。那是一个沉重的问题，那就是为什么他无法回答你。
Then the comic turns to Stacey.
然后漫画转向斯泰西。
(SINGING) Here's the mom. Mom, how old are the kids? Mom, Mom, do you know if you have kids? Dad doesn't know. Dad doesn't know how old his children are.
（歌唱）这是妈妈。妈妈，孩子们多大了？妈妈，妈妈，你知道你有孩子吗？爸爸不知道。爸爸不知道他的孩子多大了。
And then, I thought to myself, oh, now, I've got to tell the truth. And so in a split second-- very impulsive moment-- I said, I'm sorry to tell you this, but one of our kids is actually dead.
然后，我心里想，噢，现在我必须说实话了。就在那一瞬间——非常冲动的时刻——我说：“很抱歉告诉你，但我们的一个孩子其实已经去世了。”
I'm sorry to tell you, but one is actually dead.
“很抱歉告诉你，但其中一个其实已经去世了。”
No!
不！
(SINGING) Oh. Ohh. What the fuck!
（歌唱）噢。噢。搞什么！
(SINGING) Oh, my god.
（歌唱）噢，天哪。
(SINGING) Oh. RIP. RIP. RIP.
（歌唱）噢。安息。安息。安息。
(SINGING) RIP.
（歌唱）安息。
(SINGING) Ohh. Ohh. What the fuck. Ah, that's a-- I'm taking a sip of my Casa Azul.
（歌唱）噢。噢。搞什么。啊，这……我喝口酒压压惊。
On stage, no one quite knows what to do. One of the backup singers puts her hands over her face. The keyboard player just shakes his head like, no.
台上没人知道该怎么办。伴唱歌手之一捂住了脸。键盘手只是摇头，表示拒绝。
And then, I realized, like, uh-oh, I just screwed the show.
然后，我意识到，“噢，不，我刚刚把演出搞砸了。”
Ohh. (SINGING) RIP. Well, I'm so sorry. (SPEAKING) Wow, all right. (SINGING) This song has taken a turn.
噢。（歌唱）安息。好吧，我很抱歉。（说话）哇，好的。（歌唱）这首歌变调了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This moment for the comedian seems pretty insurmountable, right? Like, what could he possibly do to save his set after that? I called him up-- Adam Ray-- and he said he considered changing the subject, but chose not to.
对喜剧演员来说，这个时刻似乎不可逾越，对吧？他还能做些什么来拯救他的演出呢？我给亚当·雷打了电话，他说他曾考虑过换个话题，但选择了不。
(SINGING) This song is taking a turn. (SPEAKING) Well. Don't have kids. Don't have kids. OK. (SINGING) So that's what I'm looking for, so we can end this song on a higher note than we are right now.
（歌唱）这首歌变调了。（说话）好吧。不要孩子。不要孩子。好。（歌唱）这才是我想寻找的，这样我们就能以比现在更高的音符结束这首歌。
And finally, it's actually Stacey who saves the day. She motions for Adam the comedian, and he bends down and points his mic at her. And then she says--
最后，其实是斯泰西挽救了局面。她向喜剧演员亚当示意，他弯下腰将麦克风指向她。她说——
Our dead son would think this is hilarious.
我们的亡子会觉得这很滑稽。
I said, our dead son would think this was hilarious.
我说：“我们的亡子会觉得这很滑稽。”
(SINGING) That's the best compliment I've ever received. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, her dead son would think it's hilarious. Yeah, yeah--
（歌唱）这是我收到的最好的赞美。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，她的亡子会觉得这很滑稽。
It wasn't a lie at all. Our dead son would have thought this was hilarious. He would have been like, oh, my god, of course my mom stepped in a big pile of shit. [LAUGHS]
那根本不是谎言。我们的亡子会觉得这很滑稽。他会说：“噢，天哪，我妈果然又踩进了一堆屎里。”[笑声]
Then, Adam gets an idea.
然后，亚当有了个主意。
(SINGING) What's the name of your son who's passed on?
（歌唱）你去世的儿子叫什么名字？
Max.
马克斯。
(SINGING) His name was Max. Max. Let's give it up for Max right now.
（歌唱）他叫马克斯。马克斯。让我们现在为马克斯欢呼吧。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
(SINGING) Give it up for Max right now. Give it up for Max right now. Yeah. Give it up for Max right now. Yeah, give it up for Max right now.
（歌唱）为马克斯欢呼。为马克斯欢呼。是的。为马克斯欢呼。
Yeah, give it up for Max right now. Yeah, give it up for Max right now. Yeah, give it up for Max right now. Yeah, give it up for Max right now.
是的，为马克斯欢呼。是的，为马克斯欢呼。是的，为马克斯欢呼。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
Max, baby! You guys are amazing. Thank you so much.
马克斯，宝贝！你们太棒了。非常感谢。
The video of Adam's set actually made the rounds on TikTok and Instagram afterward. Stacey says she read every last comment-- all these people rejoicing for and remembering her son.
亚当表演的视频后来在TikTok和Instagram上流传开来。斯泰西说她读了每一条评论——所有这些人都在为她的儿子欢呼和怀念他。
I've listened to that thing, like, 100 times, I think, as I keep enjoying it.
我听了那段视频大概100次，我想，我一直很享受它。
I mean, it was like, it was incredible. It just was an incredible moment in time.
我的意思是，那简直是不可思议。那简直是一个不可思议的瞬间。
Lots of people have asked them questions, putting them in this complicated spot. But this time, in front of all those people, that ended with a room full of strangers cheering for Max-- this time is their favorite.
很多人问过他们问题，把他们置于这种尴尬的境地。但这一次，在那么多人面前，以满屋子陌生人为马克斯欢呼结束——这一次是他们最喜欢的经历。
Chris Benderev is one of the producers of our show. Coming up-- a question about a 400-year-old play and the personal question underneath that question. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
克里斯·本德雷夫是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来——一个关于400年历史戏剧的问题，以及这个问题背后个人层面的疑问。稍后回来，芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- the question trap. What we're talking about today is those questions that can seem benevolent, innocent, harmless, innocuous, could not hurt a fly. But underneath, they're really asking something else, or quietly making a point about something else. We've arrived at question three of our program-- Question Three, How's Your Mom?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“问题陷阱”。我们今天要聊的是那些看起来仁慈、天真、无害、天衣无缝的问题。但深入探究，它们其实是在问别的事情，或者在安静地强调其他观点。我们来到了节目的第三个问题：第三个问题，你妈妈怎么样？
So we spotted this next thing we want to play you in an academic journal. It was originally a paper in Medical Anthropology Quarterly, written by an anthropologist named Janelle Taylor, who adapted it to read here on the radio. This one question that Janelle Taylor is writing about-- it kept showing up all the time in her personal life. And she says, as an anthropologist, she knows, when lots of people are asking the same question over and over, it means something. And she wrote this essay to think through what is underneath that question.
我们是在一份学术期刊上发现这个我们要播给你们听的内容的。它最初是《医学人类学季刊》上的一篇论文，由一位名叫珍妮尔·泰勒的人类学家撰写，她改编后在电台朗读。珍妮尔·泰勒所写的这个问题，一直在她个人生活中反复出现。她说，作为人类学家，她知道，当很多人一遍又一遍问同一个问题时，它一定意味着什么。她写下这篇文章是为了深思那个问题背后到底是什么。
My mother is living with progressive dementia. Because I'm reading these words on the radio, I can't hear your response. But I'm listening for the question that, as I've learned, always comes.
我的母亲患有进行性痴呆。因为我是在电台上朗读这些文字，我听不到你们的回应。但我一直在等待那个我已学到、一定会来的问题。
Everyone, almost without exception, responds with some version of the same question. Does she recognize you? There are variants, of course. Does she still know who you are? But does she still know your name?
每个人，几乎无一例外，都会用同一种问题的某种形式来回应。“她认得你吗？”当然有变体。比如“她还知道你是谁吗？”或者“她还记得你的名字吗？”
However it may be phrased, the question is always whether my mother recognizes me, meaning, can she recite the facts of who I am, what my name is, and how I'm related to her? When everyone keeps asking me, Does she recognize you? I find myself thinking, that is the wrong question. I believe the question really is-- or should be-- Do you, do we, recognize her as a person who is still here?
无论怎么表述，问题总是关于我母亲是否认得我，意思是：她能说出关于我是谁、我叫什么名字、以及我们是什么关系的事实吗？当每个人都在问我“她认得你吗？”时，我发现自己想的是：那是个错误的问题。我相信真正的问题应该是——或者应该是——你、我们，是否还认出她作为一个依然存在的人？
"Does she recognize you?" The weirdness of the question becomes more obvious if you think about what would be required to answer it. Let's say I asked my mother, What's my name? Who am I? How old am I? How do we know each other?
“她认得你吗？”如果你思考回答这个问题需要什么，这个问题的荒谬性就变得更加明显了。假设我问我母亲：“我叫什么名字？我是谁？我多大了？我们是怎么认识的？”
Testing her that way-- what does it prove? What does it actually accomplish? I read a book by a journalist named Lauren Kessler. She wrote about how she would correct her own mother when her mother called her by the wrong name.
那样测试她——能证明什么？实际上完成了什么？我读过一位名叫劳伦·凯斯勒的记者的书。她写了关于她如何纠正自己的母亲，当母亲叫错她名字时。
Every time she would visit her mother, she'd take framed photos from the dresser and point to them and quiz her mother. You know who this is, don't you, Mom? Of course, she didn't.
每次她去探望母亲，她都会从梳妆台上拿起有框的照片，指着它们测试母亲。“你知道这是谁，对吧，妈？”当然，她不知道。
Kessler writes, "So I told her, again and again, each visit, who is who, and then quizzed again. Thinking back on this now, I am appalled at my insensitivity. What did I think I was doing?
凯斯勒写道：“所以我告诉她，一次又一次，每次探望都告诉她谁是谁，然后再测试。现在回想起来，我对自己当时的迟钝感到震惊。我以为自己在做什么？
I managed to accomplish only two things. I made myself miserable, and I made my mother irritable. I don't need my mother to tell me my name or how I'm related to her. I already know these things, and I know that she has dementia.
我只做成了两件事。我让自己变得痛苦，也让我母亲变得烦躁。我不需要母亲告诉我我的名字或我们是什么关系。我已经知道这些了，我也知道她患有痴呆症。
So why then would I make a point of asking her these questions that I know she can't possibly answer? It seems rude, or just mean. I can't bring myself to do it. I guess you could say that my mother raised me better than that."
那为什么我还要执着于问她那些我知道她绝不可能回答的问题呢？这看起来很粗鲁，或者只是刻薄。我无法强迫自己这样做。我想你可以说，我母亲把我教得比那好。”
"Does she recognize you?" I'm not so convinced that the inability to remember names necessarily means that a person with dementia can't recognize or care about other people. But very often, it does mean that other people stop recognizing and caring about them.
“她认得你吗？”我并不确信记忆力衰退一定意味着痴呆症患者不能认出或关心其他人。但通常情况下，这确实意味着其他人停止了认出并关心他们。
My mother was close to lots of people. But only one friend remains present in her life. Every month or two, Eli Davis drives an hour and a half from her home to Seattle to visit Mom, bringing treats and hugs and her always-cheerful self. I love her dearly for it.
我的母亲和很多人关系密切。但只有一个朋友依然存在于她的生活中。每隔一两个月，伊莱·戴维斯就会从她家开车一个半小时到西雅图探望妈妈，带着礼物、拥抱和她那一如既往快乐的自己。我非常爱她。
And I wonder, where are the others? Where are the couples with whom my parents socialized, the women with whom Mom spent hours and hours on the phone all through my childhood? This shouldn't surprise me as much as it has. Maybe it's not fair to expect friends to step up. Even close family drop off.
我好奇，其他人呢？那些和我父母社交的夫妻，那些和妈妈在我整个童年时期通电话聊上几个小时的女人们呢？这本不该让我如此惊讶。也许指望朋友们挺身而出并不公平。即使是亲近的家人也会逐渐疏远。
Friendships in America are not usually expected to survive dementia. Friendships are often more like pleasure crafts than life rafts-- not built to brave the really rough waters.
在美国，友谊通常不被期待能在痴呆症面前存活。友谊往往更像是休闲小船，而不是救生筏——不是为了度过大风大浪而建造的。
"Does she recognize you?" When people ask me whether my mother still recognizes me, they're often expressing concern for me, asking me how I'm bearing up under the burden of suffering that her dementia must place on me. And they're quite ready to hear about my burdens and my suffering.
“她认得你吗？”当人们问我母亲是否还认得我时，他们通常是在表达对我的关心，问我如何承受痴呆症带给我的痛苦重担。他们非常乐于听到我的负担和痛苦。
What they find harder to hear, I think, is that being around my mother is not a nightmare or a horror. It's not like any of that. Here's what it is.
我认为他们更难听到的是，陪伴我的母亲并不是一场噩梦或恐怖事件。根本不是那样的。情况是这样的：
In a cafe, as we share a scone, Mom and I make what passes for conversation. I've learned to ask only the sort of question that doesn't require any specific information to answer. "So, things going OK with you these days?" "How's my favorite mom doing? You doing all right?"
在咖啡馆里，我们分享一块烤饼，妈妈和我进行着勉强算得上谈话的交流。我学会了只问那种不需要具体信息来回答的问题。“最近事情还顺利吗？”“我最爱的妈妈怎么样？你还好吗？”
I tell her funny little stories about my kids. Sometimes we leaf through a magazine, looking at pictures and commenting on them. Sometimes we look out the window, and I make general observations that require no specific response.
我给她讲关于我孩子们的趣事。有时我们翻看杂志，看图评论。有时我们看着窗外，我做一些不需要具体回应的一般性观察。
"Looks like spring is coming." "Look at those leaves coming out on the trees." "That guy's hair is really curly." With each exchange, Mom smiles at me, beaming affectionately in that familiar, slightly conspiratorial way, as if we're both in on the same joke.
“看起来春天要来了。”“看那些树上长出的叶子。”“那个人的头发真卷。”每一次交流，妈妈都对着我微笑，那种熟悉而略带同谋感的深情，仿佛我们俩都在分享同一个笑话。
So our conversations go nowhere. But it doesn't matter what we say, really, or whether we said it before, or whether it's accurate or interesting or even comprehensible. The exchange is the point.
所以我们的对话哪里也没去。但我们说什么其实不重要，或者我们之前是否说过，或者它是否准确、有趣，甚至能否理解。交流本身就是重点。
Mom and I are playing catch with touches, smiles, and gestures, as well as words, lobbing them back and forth to each other in slow, easy, underhand arcs. The fact that she drops the ball more and more often doesn't stop the game from being enjoyable. It's a way of being together.
妈妈和我在进行一场用触摸、微笑和手势，以及言语进行的接球游戏，将它们以缓慢、轻松、低手的弧线互相来回抛掷。她丢球的次数越来越多，并没有阻止这场游戏变得有趣。这是一种在一起的方式。
"Does she recognize you?" She may not recognize me, in a narrowly cognitive sense. But my mom does recognize me as someone who's there with her, someone familiar, perhaps. And she doesn't need to have all the details sorted out in order to care for me.
“她认得你吗？”她在狭义的认知意义上可能不认得我。但我的妈妈确实认得我是一个和她在一起的人，或许是一个熟悉的人。她不需要搞清楚所有的细节来关心我。
The impulse to care, the habit of caring-- these are things that run deep in my mother-- someone who, for most of her life, was very engaged in caring for other people-- her children, her husband, her grandchildren, her friends. Even some of the behavioral quirks that my mom has developed make sense to me in those terms-- as expressions of care.
关心的冲动，关心的习惯——这些在我母亲心中根深蒂固——她大半生都在非常投入地照顾别人——她的孩子们、丈夫、孙子们、朋友们。甚至我母亲发展出的一些行为怪癖，对我来说也能解释得通——作为关心的表达。
Here's an example. People with dementia often engage in repetitive behaviors, and Mom is no exception. When I take her out to a cafe, I usually get a cup of black coffee for myself and order a cup of hot chocolate for her. Not too hot, and don't forget the whipped cream on top.
举个例子。痴呆症患者经常会进行重复性行为，妈妈也不例外。当我带她去咖啡馆时，我通常会给自己买杯黑咖啡，给她点杯热巧克力。不要太热，别忘了上面的鲜奶油。
As we drink them, she checks constantly to see whether my cup and hers are even, whether the liquids have been drunk down to the same level. And if not, she'll hurry up and drink more to catch up, or else, stop and wait for me. Or if we share a cookie, she's concerned to make sure that the haves be the same size and that we eat them at the same rate.
当我们喝的时候，她会不停地检查我的杯子和她的杯子是否平衡，液体是否喝到了同样的高度。如果不平衡，她会赶快多喝点赶上，或者停下来等我。或者如果我们分享一块饼干，她会很担心，确保剩下的部分大小一样，且我们吃它们的速度是一样的。
I think keeping track of whether our drinks and cookies are even comes naturally to my mother-- a woman who has always had to carefully divide quite limited resources-- first, with her own brothers, and later, among her four children. She's cared about such details all her life, and caring about them was also a way in which she cared for other people.
我觉得关注我们的饮料和饼干是否平衡是母亲的天性——她一生都必须小心翼翼地分配相当有限的资源——最初是和她自己的兄弟们，后来是在她四个孩子之间。她一生都在关注这些细节，关注这些也是她照顾别人的一种方式。
Mom also does still take care of me, in some small but important ways. One time, a little more than a year ago, I stopped by the assisted living facility where she was living at the end of a very busy day in an especially hectic week. I had stayed up very late the night before, trying to finish grading student papers, then spent the whole day teaching and in meetings.
妈妈确实还在照顾我，以一些微小但重要的方式。有一次，大概一年多前，我在一个非常忙碌的星期结束时，顺路去探望她住的养老院。前一天晚上我熬得很晚，试图批改学生论文，然后整天都在教书和开会。
I went with her up to her room. I turned on the TV, and we sat down together on the couch. I was exhausted. I leaned back and yawned.
我和她一起回到房间。我打开电视，我们在沙发上坐下。我精疲力竭。我靠在椅背上，打了个哈欠。
Mom patted my hand and said to me, You're tired. Just go ahead and sleep. You can just lay down right here. And so I sat there next to my mom, holding her hand, feeling her warmth against me, all along one side of my body. And I leaned my head on her shoulder and slept.
妈妈拍了拍我的手，对我说：“你累了。去睡觉吧。你可以就躺在这里。”于是我坐在妈妈旁边，握着她的手，感受着她身体的温暖，就在我身体的一侧。我把头靠在她的肩膀上睡着了。
"Does she recognize you?" For a while after we first moved my mother into an assisted living facility, she often said that she wanted to "go home." I understood this to mean that she wanted to move back to the house where she had lived for 40 years until my father's death, the house in which I grew up.
“她认得你吗？”在我们刚把母亲搬进养老院后的一段时间里，她经常说她想“回家”。我理解这指的是她想搬回父亲去世前她住了40年的那所房子，也就是我长大的那所房子。
Usually, I responded with my own mild version of reality orientation, explaining as gently as possible that that house was all empty and cold now, and nobody was there to keep her company or help her do stuff, so it was probably better to stay here. One time, though, I asked her a question instead-- "You mean, home to the house up in Edmonds?"
通常，我用我温和的现实定向方式回应，尽可能温柔地解释那所房子现在空荡荡的，很冷，没有人在那儿陪她或帮她做事情，所以呆在这里可能更好。有一次，我却反问了她一个问题——“你是说，回埃德蒙兹的那所房子？”
"No, on the farm," she answered. ''You go down--" With her raised arm, she traced out the curve of a long-ago road. For the first few years of her life, my mother had lived on a small farm in southern Idaho, before her father moved the family to Seattle during World War II to seek work on the docks.
“不，回农场，”她回答。“你去那儿——”她抬起手臂，划出了一条很久以前路的弧线。在我母亲生命的前几年，她住在爱达荷州南部的一个小农场里，后来二战期间，她父亲把全家搬到了西雅图，以便在码头找工作。
"They're inside there," she added. "Who?" I asked. "My mom and my dad." My mother's in her 70s. Her parents are not waiting for her inside an Idaho farmhouse.
“他们就在里面，”她补充道。“谁？”我问。“我妈妈和我爸爸。”我母亲70多岁了。她的父母并没有在爱达荷州的农舍里等她。
You could use that evidence to draw a clear line between us. Me here, on the side of reality, competence, personhood, recognition; her over there, on the side of delusion, incapacity, not quite fully human.
你可以用那些证据在我们之间划出一条清晰的界线。我在这里，站在现实、能力、人格、认知的这一边；她在那里，站在幻想、无能、不够完全人性的那一边。
But what she was longing for was her childhood home. She missed her mom and dad. She was trying, in her own way, to hold on to them, just as I was trying, against the odds, to hold on to her. Our predicament is exactly the same.
但她所渴望的是她童年的家。她想念她的妈妈和爸爸。她正在以自己的方式试图留住他们，就像我正在试图违背规律留住她一样。我们的处境完全一样。
Janelle Taylor-- she is a professor at the University of Toronto, teaching medical anthropology. Her mom, Charlene Taylor, died in 2019. Janelle is collecting this essay and others about dementia into a book. You can find a link to the original academic article that she wrote at our website.
珍妮尔·泰勒——她是多伦多大学教授医学人类学的教授。她的母亲，夏琳·泰勒，在2019年去世了。珍妮尔正在将这篇文章和其他关于痴呆症的文章整理成书。你可以在我们的网站找到她写的原始学术文章的链接。
Act Four, Can I Help You? OK, here's one last example of a question that has another question lurking behind it. Question goes like this.
第四部分，我能帮你吗？好了，这是最后一个关于背后潜伏着另一个问题的例子。问题是这样的。
If Matthew scored an average of 15 points per basketball game and played 24 games in one season, how many points did he score in the season? That's a question from the SHSAT, which is a standardized test given to middle school students in New York City. A high score on the SHSAT will get you into one of the eight top public schools in the city-- wonderful schools. A low score will keep you in the regular public school system, where your school may be assigned by lottery.
如果马修每场篮球赛平均得15分，一个赛季打了24场比赛，他在那个赛季总共得了多少分？这是纽约市给初中生参加的标准化考试SHSAT中的一道数学题。在SHSAT中取得高分将让你进入纽约市八所顶级公立学校之一——很棒的学校。低分将让你留在常规公立学校系统，在那儿你的学校可能是通过抽签分配的。
So the question lurking behind that math question is, Are you good enough? Are you good enough to go to the best schools? And maybe from there, to the best colleges? And from there, to all the advantages you get from that kind of education, including a higher income, maybe a better job, all other sorts of stuff? Kind of a big scary chasm opening up in the Earth behind that innocent little math problem.
所以，那个数学题背后潜伏的问题是：你足够好吗？你足够好到能进入最好的学校吗？进而进入最好的大学？再进而得到那种教育带来的所有优势，包括更高的收入、更好的工作，以及其他各种东西？在那道天真的小数学题背后，简直像是一道巨大的、可怕的深渊在大地上裂开。
In 2017--
2017年——
For five years, Milo Cramer tutored kids who wanted to leap over that chasm and into those eight elite high schools. It first made Milo feel good.
五年来，米洛·克雷默一直在辅导那些想跨越那道深渊、进入那八所精英高中的孩子们。起初这让米洛感觉很好。
Because I thought I was helping children. And I only gradually came to understand that I was really just a fucked-up cog in a larger, fucked-up system.
因为我觉得我在帮助孩子。但我逐渐意识到，我其实只是一个更大、更混乱系统中一个混乱的齿轮。
This recording is from a one-person show that Milo did this fall about the kids they tutored. I worry a little that it's going to be hard to get across over the radio what's so special about this show. Most of it is songs-- songs about the kids that Milo tutored-- these very funny and heartbreaking portraits of these middle school and high school kids and Milo's relationship to them. Like, for example, the boy who takes a lot of pleasure denouncing God and the Democrats.
这段录音来自于米洛今年秋天做的一场独角戏，关于他们辅导过的孩子们。我有点担心通过电台传达这场演出的特殊之处会很困难。其中大部分是歌曲——关于米洛辅导的孩子们的歌——这些关于这些初中和高中孩子及其与米洛关系，非常有趣且令人心碎的肖像。比如，那个对诅咒上帝和民主党人感到非常愉悦的男孩。
(SINGING) Jason's 16, and he proudly identifies as libertarian. He's a 16-year-old libertarian. I'm kind of afraid of him.
（歌唱）杰森16岁，他自豪地认同自己是自由意志主义者。他是一个16岁的自由意志主义者。我有点怕他。
Milo is not a great singer. They would tell you that themself. Or a skilled musician. But they've written songs in secret since they were the age that these kids are that they're writing about.
米洛不是个伟大的歌手。他们自己会告诉你这一点。也不是个熟练的音乐家。但他们从这些孩子现在的年纪就开始秘密写歌了。
And there's just something in the intentional roughness and sincerity of what they're doing that kind of matches the rawness of these kids and their feelings-- and of Milo's reactions to them. When a girl from Queens named Dana, who's better at math than Milo, and probably should be a scientist or engineer someday, tells Milo that if she does end up in college, she wants to study theater, Milo, who's broke and struggling and wanting to do theater, sings--
而且在他们所做的故意粗糙和真诚之中，有一种东西与这些孩子们及他们的感受，还有米洛对他们的反应的原始感相呼应。当一个来自皇后区的女孩叫达娜，她在数学上比米洛好，可能以后应该成为科学家或工程师，告诉米洛如果她真的能上大学，她想学戏剧时，破产、挣扎、想做戏剧的米洛唱道——
(SINGING) I want to tell her not to! I want to tell her not to! You cannot study theater! You have to study math! You're good at math! You're failing math?! You want to study theater?! Theater doesn't matter! There's a pandemic!
（歌唱）我想告诉她别去！我想告诉她别去！你不能学戏剧！你必须学数学！你数学很好！你数学不及格？！你想学戏剧？！戏剧不重要！有流行病！
Lots of the songs in the show are about the kids' anxieties about school and this test and all the pressure they feel from their parents. And they're about Milo trying to figure out not just how to teach them, but what they possibly could say to comfort them. Faith, for example, is a terrible reader.
演出中的许多歌都是关于孩子们对学校和这次考试的焦虑，以及他们从父母那里感受到的所有压力。这些歌是关于米洛在试图搞清楚不仅是如何教他们，还有他可能对他们说什么来安慰他们。比如，费思是个糟糕的读者。
(SINGING) Faith says, I think I'm stupid. I can't read. I guess I'm stupid. I get Bs. I must be stupid. I say, I don't think you're stupid. Faith repeats, I'm sure I'm stupid. If you think I'm smart, please prove it.
（歌唱）费思说：“我觉得我很蠢。我不会读。我想我很蠢。我拿B。我一定很蠢。”我说：“我不觉得你蠢。”费思重复道：“我肯定我很蠢。如果你觉得我聪明，请证明它。”
I tell her, intelligence is unmeasurable and different in every individual. Faith just looks at me and says, no. I say, yes. She says, no. She says, no, no, no, no.
我告诉她，智力是不可衡量的，在每个人身上都是不同的。费思只是看着我说：“不。”我说：“是的。”她说：“不。”她说：“不，不，不，不。”
I say, hey, when I was your age, my mom hid all my report cards from me. When I asked her what my grades were, she always told me, you're right where you should be. You're right where you should be.
我说：“嘿，当我像你这么大时，我妈把所有成绩单都藏起来了。当我问她我的成绩时，她总是告诉我：‘你就在你应该在的地方。你就在你应该在的地方。’”
Our radio show that is about questions. And to close out the show, I'm just going to play you one more thing. This is one full song from Milo's show about a question that a student faced. It's an essay question.
我们的广播节目是关于问题的。为了结束节目，我再放一首歌。这是来自米洛演出的一整首歌，关于一个学生面临的一个问题。这是一个议论文问题。
(SINGING) Divya has to respond to the question, Is Shakespeare's Othello racist? in a five-paragraph essay for her white teacher by Monday. And she says, just tell me the answer, please. I have so much homework this week.
（歌唱）迪维娅周一必须为她的白人老师完成一篇五段式文章，回应这个问题：“莎士比亚的《奥赛罗》是种族主义的吗？”她说：“只要告诉我答案，拜托。我这周有很多家庭作业。”
I need to get this done as fast as possible. Is Othello racist? Yes or no? I'm like, have you read the play? She's like, yes, and I watched the Laurence Fishburne movie.
我需要尽快完成这个。奥赛罗是种族主义者吗？是还是不是？我说：“你读过剧本了吗？”她说：“是的，我看了劳伦斯·菲什伯恩的电影。”
I'm like, great, so what do you think? She's like, I don't know. I'm 15. I'm afraid to say the wrong thing. I'm like, same.
我说：“太好了，那你怎么看？”她说：“我不知道。我15岁。我怕说错话。”我说：“我也是。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
This stuff is hard to talk about, but you've got to trust yourself, even though you've also got to constantly question and interrogate yourself. Either way, you've got to try. You've got to try. You've got to try, try, try, try, try.
这些东西很难谈论，但你必须相信自己，尽管你也必须不断质疑和审视自己。无论如何，你必须尝试。你必须尝试。你必须尝试，尝试，尝试，尝试，尝试。
I'm desperate to do a good job. Divya's Indian-American mom can hear us in the next room. I do not know what to do. Divya looks at the assignment rubric to see how she'll be graded.
我非常渴望做好这份工作。迪维娅的印度裔美国母亲能在隔壁房间听到我们。我不知道该怎么办。迪维娅看着作业评分表，看她会被如何打分。
She needs a clear, defensible thesis, followed by three unique body paragraphs. I can tell she's overwhelmed. I say, remember, grades don't matter, Divya. Learning can't be measured. Just trust how you feel you did.
她需要一个清晰、可辩护的论点，跟着三个独特的正文段落。我看得出她被压得透不过气来。我说：“记住，分数不重要，迪维娅。学习是不可衡量的。只要相信你做得很棒的感觉。”
She says, maybe grades don't matter if you're rich, but in my family, grades are so important. I think I thought at first that Divya didn't have the words to talk about the play in any nuanced way. But now, I start to think that her understanding is deeper than my own.
她说：“也许如果你有钱分数不重要，但在我们家，分数非常重要。”我想起初我以为迪维娅没有词汇以任何微妙的方式谈论这出戏。但现在，我开始认为她的理解比我更深。
And she might never talk to me about Othello honestly and shouldn't have to. Finally, I decide she just wants me to provide her with some easy answer to satisfy her teacher and get her through the semester unscathed. So I'm like--
而且她可能永远不会诚实地跟我谈论《奥赛罗》，也不应该被要求这样做。最后，我决定她只是想让我给她提供一些简单的答案来满足她的老师，并让她安然度过本学期。所以我说——
(SPEAKING) OK.
（说话）好的。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Your teacher is either looking for an essay that's like, yes, Othello is very racist. The story of the play is, there's this super professionally and romantically successful Black man all of these white guys are jealous of and cannot handle. That tension is resolved when the white guys trick Othello into murdering his wife, thereby turning him into the brutish stereotype they wanted him to be all along. That the title role was performed in blackface for centuries underscores this.
你的老师要么是在找一篇像“是的，奥赛罗是非常种族主义的”的文章。这出戏的故事是，有一个非常专业且浪漫上成功的黑人男性，所有白人家伙都嫉妒他且无法应付。那种张力在白人家伙诱骗奥赛罗谋杀他妻子时得到解决，从而把他变成他们一直想要的野蛮刻板印象。标题角色几个世纪以来一直由黑脸表演，这一点强调了这一点。
Moreover-- That's a good-- that's kind of a transition word, Divya-- "moreover," i.e. "my next body paragraph will be about." Moreover, Desdemona's whiteness, in contrast, is repeatedly presented as innately good, innocent, and desirable. That's one essay you could write that would get an A.
而且——那是个很好的过渡词，迪维娅——“而且”，即“我的下一个正文段落将是关于”。而且，德斯德蒙娜的白皙，相比之下，被反复表现为天生善良、无辜和令人向往。那是一篇你可以写出能拿到A的文章。
The other essay you could write that would also get an A goes, no, Othello is not super racist. Othello is a flawed attempt at anti-racism, in that it's Shakespeare's only play to center a dynamic Black protagonist. The play was banned in apartheid South Africa for depicting an interracial relationship. Moreover--
你能写的另一篇也能拿到A的文章是：“不，奥赛罗不是超级种族主义者。奥赛罗是一个反种族主义的缺陷尝试，因为它是莎士比亚唯一以动态黑人主角为中心的戏剧。这出戏在南非种族隔离时期被禁止，因为它描绘了跨种族关系。而且——”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
The play's most prejudiced characters are always presented as either stupid, Rodrigo, or evil, Iago. It would be a mistake to conflate the perspectives of these characters with the meanings of the work as a whole. Either of those essays would get As, Divya.
这出戏最带有偏见的性格总是被表现为愚蠢（罗德里戈）或者邪恶（伊阿古）。将这些角色的观点与作品作为一个整体的含义混为一谈是一个错误。这两篇文章都能拿到A，迪维娅。
But what your teacher's reductive yes-or-no prompt does not allow for is an essay that's like, what I think I think, which is something like, Othello is a product and reflection of another culture, Elizabethan England, 400 years old, written at a time when race was just being invented as a system of power. The play later became a cultural export of the British Empire, which colonized Black and Brown people around the world. The play remains a bestseller of the Shakespeare-industrial complex.
但你老师的还原论式是/否提示所不允许的是一篇这样的文章：我所认为的我所想的，大概是这样的，奥赛罗是另一种文化——伊丽莎白时代的英国，400年前的产品和反映，写于种族刚被发明为一种权力系统时。这出戏后来成为大英帝国的文化出口，殖民了世界各地的黑人和棕色人种。这出戏仍然是莎士比亚工业复合体的畅销书。
In other words, Divya, Othello and racism are so indelibly linked, that the question, Is Othello racist? seems to confuse both what racism is and what artworks are. In my opinion, what's really racist, Divya, is that we are required to read Othello for the billionth time, that it's on the curriculum at your Brooklyn public high school, even though the play is boring--
换句话说，迪维娅，《奥赛罗》和种族主义联系得如此不可磨灭，以至于这个问题“奥赛罗是种族主义的吗？”似乎混淆了什么是种族主义以及什么是艺术品。在我看来，真正种族主义的是，迪维娅，我们被要求第一百万次阅读《奥赛罗》，它在布鲁克林公立高中的课程表上，尽管这出戏很无聊——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--when we could be reading any number of contemporary Black playwrights.
——当我们本可以阅读任何数量的当代黑人剧作家时。
[STRUMMING UKULELE]
[尤克里里弹奏]
(SINGING) Divya responds, don't hate me, but I kind of liked reading Othello. The story is really crazy, and the language is really pretty.
（歌唱）迪维娅回答：“别讨厌我，但我有点喜欢读《奥赛罗》。故事真的很疯狂，语言真的很美。”
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
[笑声，掌声]
Milo Cramer, in the one-person show, School Pictures, recorded at Playwrights Horizons in New York. To hear more songs for the show or to book them to come to your town, go to milocramer.com. That's Cramer with a C-- milocramer.com.
米洛·克雷默，在独角戏《学校照片》中，录制于纽约剧作家地平线剧院。要听更多节目中的歌曲或预定他们来你的城市，请访问milocramer.com。那是克雷默的C——milocramer.com。
Well, our program was produced today by Zoe Chace. The people who put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Bethel Habte, Chana Joffe-Walt, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Safiya Riddle, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好了，我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯制作。今天节目的幕后人员包括詹达伊·邦兹、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、贝塞尔·哈布特、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、萨菲亚·里德尔、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃曼纽尔·贝里。
Original music for the comedian story by Ryan Rumery, who also helped mix the show. Special thanks today to Lauren Kessler. Her book is Finding Life in the Land of Alzheimer's.
喜剧故事的原创音乐由瑞安·鲁梅里制作，他也协助了节目的混音。特别感谢劳伦·凯斯勒。她的书是《在阿尔茨海默氏症的土地上寻找生命》。
Also thanks to Galya Walt, Michael Rosenthal, Diana Taylor-William, Mike Taylor, Pat Taylor, David Johnson, Rachel Jackson, Tom O'Keefe, and Jolie Myers.
也要感谢加利亚·沃尔特、迈克尔·罗森塔尔、戴安娜·泰勒-威廉、迈克·泰勒、帕特·泰勒、大卫·约翰逊、雷切尔·杰克逊、汤姆·奥基夫和朱莉·迈尔斯。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。感谢一如既往，我们节目的混淆者，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, he kind of hurt my feelings this morning. We ran into each other. He asked, How am I doing? I started to answer, then he was like--
你知道，他今天早上伤了我的心。我们碰面了。他问我：“最近怎么样？”我开始回答，然后他——
(SINGING) Well, who cares? Who cares? Who cares? Who cares?
（歌唱）嗯，谁在乎呢？谁在乎呢？谁在乎呢？谁在乎呢？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。